une conférence de presse sans grande
annonce ce jeudi le premier ministre
jean castex a présenté une esquisse du
calendrier de la levée des restrictions
avec en premier lieu la réouverture des
crèches et des écoles
une rentrée possible dès lundi grâce à
une baisse des cas quotidiens de
contamination au covit 19
selon le chef du gouvernement le pic de
la troisième vague de l'épidémie semble
bel et bien derrière nous l'amélioration
relative mais réel de la situation
sanitaire et les mesures renforcé de
protections aux frontières nous
permettent aujourd'hui de confirmer la
reprise des enseignements scolaires la
semaine prochaine
comme l'avait annoncé le président de la
république dès ce lundi 26 avril tous
les élèves des écoles maternelles
élémentaires ainsi que leurs enseignants
regagneront leurs classes fidèle en cela
à notre objectif depuis la fin du
premier confinement d'assurer aux élèves
la continuité de ce lien physique le
plus qu'il soit possible
une rentrée sous haute surveillance avec
la mise en place d'un protocole très
strict et le renforcement massif des
tests en milieu scolaire une attention
toute particulière sera portée aux
écoles situées dans les départements où
l'incidence est la plus élevée ce seront
dès la semaine prochaine plus de tests
salivaires pour les écoles élémentaires
nous en réalisons 250000 par semaine
fin mars nous en proposerons 400000 par
semaine à la reprise avec la perspective
d'atteindre 6 charmilles tests d'ici la
mi-mai une réouverture est essentielle
pour le premier ministre afin de
préserver le lien social et d'éviter
l'augmentation du taux d'échec scolaire
en france après une semaine
d'enseignement à distance les collégiens
et lycéens retrouveront eux aussi les
bancs de l'école dès le 3 mai prochain
date décisive puisqu'elle marquera la
levée des restrictions de déplacement en
journée dans l'hexagone à partir du 3
mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement en journée et en visa
et se réserve de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire un nouveau train de
réouverture autour de la mi mai qui
pourrait commencer par les commerces
certaines activités culturelles et
sportives et les terrasses
cette liste n'est pas définitivement
fixée elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
le premier ministre l'admets cette
annonce de réouverture des commerces
restent flous sans date précise
difficile de s'organiser pour bon nombre
de commerçants
parmi eux les restaurateurs ils restent
dans l'attenté de prochaines annonces
afin de préciser ce calendrier de
déconfinement emmanuel macron devrait
prendre la parole
d'ici la semaine prochaine